hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll and you might
notice I'm still in that mode where my
voice is not a hundred percent sorry
about that you know the times when you
listen to the podcasts are not obviously
correlated with the times when I'm
recording the intros to the podcasts
which are obviously not correlated to
the times when I record the main part of
the podcast this is a spread out over
time kind of operation we have here at
mindscape so sorry about that
but hopefully I'm understandable because
I want to talk about a little bit
different thing for the podcast today
we're gonna dive into history
everyone knows that it's important to
try to learn lessons from history right
we have things going on right now we
live in a time here in the United States
and in the world where history is
happening all around us it's interesting
to go to look into the past to try to
learn lessons for what we should be
doing now but it's easy to be too
superficial about that right it's easy
to point to the Nazis and compare
everything to the Nazis and I'm sure
back way back in the day they compared
everything to the Mongols and Genghis
Khan and worried about the Mongols
there's lots of things that happened in
history and all of them can teach us
something but in subtly different ways
so today we're going to examine a
crucial time in history and tease out
some of the possible implications for
the present but we're gonna try not to
be too simplistic we're gonna leave most
of the implications to your minds
today's guest is Edward Watts who is a
Pulitzer Prize winning historian at UC
San Diego his work focuses on the Roman
Empire in times and places around that
but what we're gonna talk about today is
actually the decline of the Roman
Republic the transitional period that
ended the republican-led in to the Roman
Empire
you know the Roman Empire looms large in
our cultural background but the Roman
Republic that preceded it lasted for
five hundred years and was very
successful it was a wonderful example of
a long-lasting stable democracy /
Republic and then it changed it went
into an empire and you know the Empire
had various good qualities but still you
don't get to vote that people don't have
a voice in an empire system like the UN
Republic system so what
happened of course being that it's the
Roman Empire we know a lot
there were people writing about what was
happening and they're not always
reliable we have to extrapolate and use
our wits a little bit but there's a
whole bunch of stories about what
happened in those last hundred hundred
and fifty years before the fall of the
Republic I'm particularly fond of the
story of the Gracchi brothers I didn't
know about this probably some of the
history buffs in the audience this is
old news but there are two politicians
in the late Roman Republic who on the
one hand you can argue or trying to do
good things for the people of Rome
broadly construed for the people the
Republic on the other hand they had a
tendency to sort of violate the norms by
which the government was running and the
Republic was operating so there's a
debate right I mean when do you violate
the norms when is it sufficiently bad
the conditions that are going on around
you that you need to take dramatic
action it's easy to make an argument
that the norms just benefit the well-off
right however their norm violation one
can also argue led to the normalization
of the use of violence to achieve
political ends which then contributed to
the decline and fall of the Republic and
replaced by a monarchy so what lessons
we want to draw from that is it's never
easy I'm not going to be actually
telling you what the right lessons are I
do think though that the more we know
and understand history the more informed
our choices will be going forward so
let's go
[Music]
every Watts welcome in the mindscape
podcast thank you I'm glad to be here so
I think it'll come as no surprise that
I'm not a professional historian in fact
I think it's safe to say most of my
knowledge of the history of Rome comes
from Shakespeare plays and and I think I
can even go further and say that's
probably not that atypical to think that
when people say ancient Rome I think of
the Empire but they say that's what I
think of it's the cool interesting part
of the history of Rome but there was a
republic for hundreds of years before
that and there is even a kingdom before
that so we're interested in the Republic
and especially its latter days but let's
set up how we got to the Republic like
because the even the Kingdom was kind of
interesting it wasn't her hereditary
crown like we think of now right yeah I
think that thinking about Roman history
across its full scope is really
intriguing because the Roman state such
as it is is there for twenty two hundred
years it starts with the Roman Kingdom
and it ends with canons and the fall of
Constantinople in 1453 yeah
and there's very very few things in
history we have that much continuity but
seeing how it starts in some ways looks
radically different from how it ends but
in other ways the continuity is very
easy to see and so the the Roman state
when it starts up is a monarchy as best
we can tell but it's a monarchy in which
the king is dependent on and interacting
with this group of hereditary
aristocracy that the king generally
belongs to and so the monarchy is
something in which the the king is
chosen from among this group of
patricians the king is accountable to
this group of patrician and when the
King dies power goes back to the group
of patricians and each of the leading
members of each family take a turn
auditioning as king and after a year
passes one of them is chosen and he's
king for the rest of his life and at the
end of that power goes back to the
patricians what happens towards the end
of the monarchy is there is a what I
suppose we would call almost a class
revolt where the nature of power in the
Roman state has begin to begun to shift
and you have an imbalance between the
people who
to the register hereditary aristocracy
and the people who are becoming wealthy
and there are people outside of this
aris doctors that you start becoming
wealthy and you have a king who seizes
power on the basis of appealing to these
newly wealthy but politically not
completely disenfranchised but largely
disenfranchised people the nouveau riche
yeah right right and what ends up
happening is the patricians lose control
of this accountability that they've had
that have governed their interactions
with the king now the king is
accountable to other people what the
Republic represents is the patrician
counter-revolution where these Kings who
are loyal to this new sort of
class-based structure are now not
listening to patricians in a way that
really discourages patricians and
patricians overthrow this new kingship
structure and create something that
starts out as the patricians running
things without a king at all right and
this is how the Republic starts it's an
incredibly conservative move and the
idea of the Republic appealed to these
patricians in large part because the
Roman Republic like a modern Republic is
a state in which everybody has a voice
but the voice is not allocated equally
yeah some people have more of a voice
right and when the Republic starts
patricians have much more of a voice
than anybody else I should say for
listeners at home if you hear a little
bits of moaning and squealing in the
background that's our local dog Juno she
has opinions and she'll cheat tripping
that's perfectly fine
so the patricians so that when the early
days of the Republic
it wasn't everyone gets a vote right so
the patricians and who chooses the
patricians how do you get to be a
patrician so you're a patrician simply
because you belong to a family that's
patrician there are cases where people
get moved into this order and this is
the thing that's really challenging for
us you know we've been trained to think
of societies that are hierarchical
mainly organized on class and in the
Roman Republic it's not the patrician
order has nothing to do with how wealthy
you are and part of the challenge
that the roman republic faces is there
are non patricians which Romans called
plebeians who were wealthier than some
patricians yeah and the republic
struggled for about 200 years to figure
out how you balance the authority that
that rich plebeians can claim in the
rest of society with the authority of
the patricians of irrigated to
themselves in the republic and
eventually what they come up with is a
series of messy compromises where
plebeians are able to hold assemblies
and vote on laws without patricians
being involved but the laws are supposed
to actually bind everybody in the state
including patricians okay and the series
of compromises that unfold are
deliberately messy and there's ambiguity
that is left where plebeians have
authority that if they exercise that to
its fullest extent could be used to do
really horrible things to patricians
they choose not to I mean patricians
have ways to block plebeians from doing
these things as well and they choose not
to and instead you have this very
elegant system where the laws provide
certain ways to exercise power but their
understandings unwritten understandings
but deeply understood ideas about what
is not acceptable you know you you can't
push your powers to the fullest extent
imagine those little things just aren't
done it's destabilizing yeah right and
it's in no one's interest to do that I
know if you're a patrician
destabilization leads to violence and
probably that's going to end badly for
you and one thing I noticed that there
was this yeah I don't even think of it
but there were votes there were ballots
but they were public like when you voted
people know who you voted for right and
the innovation of a secret ballot was a
big deal were laughing at you know if he
does not like secret ballots but that's
okay we'll go along with it yeah for the
first 350 years of the Republic your
ballot was something that actually was
spoken you know it was it was obvious
who you were voting for and the idea
there was you were accountable you know
and the other idea there that was sort
of buried beneath this is if somebody
paid you for your vote which was illegal
but was done
and done pretty regularly they could
tell whether payment actually worked but
when you move to secret ballots the
initial secret balloting consists of a
piece of paper and you would walk down a
plank and then you would drop this into
a basket but people could stand there
and see what was on the piece of paper
yeah and a series of reforms in the 130s
get you from you have to announce your
vote loud and clear so everybody can
hear it to a very narrow walkway where
no one can actually observe what you've
written on the piece of paper so it was
more really secret it was really secret
at that point and that annoyed some
people I didn't like it it annoyed a lot
of people how can i bribe people if they
won't stay bribed if I don't know what
they're voting for and the interesting
thing is it's quite possible that you
could then take multiple bribes right
and this was in some ways something that
was supposed to discourage political
malfeasance because you didn't actually
know if you got what you paid for right
and you didn't actually know whether
this person just you took money from six
different people and voted for two of
them and what could you do okay but that
is a relatively late thing I do want to
just sort of put ourselves in the
mindset of understanding the Roman
Republic I mean it wasn't the first
exercise in democracy in the ancient
world you know it came after the
Athenian democracy but was it the first
Republic was the idea of a republic
around
I mean how I guess well in the United
States were in the French Revolution we
think about being influenced by
philosophers right yeah Locke and
Rousseau and Hobbes what was there an
explicit idea there was some
philosophical justification for doing
things one way rather than another well
so when we compared the Roman Republic
to Athenian democracy I think it's
important to say that Romans would have
found athenian style democracy
absolutely abhorrent
there wasn't any assembly that was based
on that principle where a majority would
just vote would vote and then that would
give us a khakhra see yeah and if it's
fifty fifty percent plus one that
decided it what the Roman assemblies
tended to do is they grouped people
together in certain ways and the votes
would be counted in the context of a
voting tribe or a voting century and
whatever that
majority was would count as one vote
towards whatever decision was being made
so your vote was always channeled
through some other structure and the
Romans felt that this was this was ideal
they never in any sense wanted this to
be a situation where people just could
carry an idea on the basis of having 50
plus one so it was almost like
government by deliberation and consensus
rather than just majority rules exactly
the basic idea that governed what Romans
were doing was a principle of it's
better to do nothing than to do the
wrong thing and it's better to do
nothing than to do something that a very
narrow majority of the population
supports and the idea behind that and
they don't articulate this in the way
that a Greek political thinker would
articulate this but the idea behind that
was once you make a decision that a
large number of people in this state
have signed on to they own it yeah and
it's very hard then to step back and say
this was terrible we need to we need to
turn around can't just blame the other
party and Athenian democracy did that
all the time I mean the case of
Alcibiades is the greatest example of
this where they send him out to command
a fleet in three days later they send
another ship saying no way to come back
the Roman Republic didn't work that way
and it was by design yeah there was no
interest on the part of Romans in
empowering the people to the point where
you could have these radical changes in
policy instead what was supposed to
happen and a lot of times did happen
most of the time did happen was all of
the stakeholders would come together and
propose an idea and try to make that
idea workable to the broadest broadest
group of people in the Roman state so
you could get this consensus and it was
pretty successful writing me roam both
flourished internally and expanded a
great deal in this time like when when
is the beginning to end of the Roman
Republic so conventionally the Roman
Republic starts in 509 BC there's some
debate about that date but I think
generally speaking it's a good starting
point it ends effectively somewhere
between
30 and 27 BC okay yeah you have almost
500 years almost 500 years but if you
were to ask the Emperor Augustus what
sort of state do you live under he would
say it's a republic you have people who
claim that there still there's still
elements of the republic that are still
sort of percolating through roman life
into the Augustan period and even past
augustus but i think if you asked any
roman who was going to answer honestly
they would say the republic ended around
27 BC okay but it did it did flourish
over those 500 years yeah yeah and for
the first almost 400 of it the Republic
was remarkably successful in doing more
or less what it was charged to do
creating an entity that prevented
anybody from assuming power by
themselves and creating a political
process that governed the rights and
prevented violence exercises and
violence violent conflict that dominated
a political life and what the Republic
did was it promised effectively peace
and freedom from tyranny and who worth
stakeholders I mean who got a vote in
some sense every citizen how to vote and
what it was mean be a citizen of Rome so
the the other genius at the Romans had
and this made them almost entirely
unique in the ancient world the Romans
extended citizenship quite widely so the
city of Rome of course when it's founded
this is the the core of Roman
citizenship but as the city of Rome
conquered more territories Romans
awarded citizenship to people that they
conquered not everybody and not all the
time but in large enough quantities that
you reach a point by the end of the
second century BC where there are
millions of people who exercise some
form of Roman citizenship and as the
Republic expands the number of places
that enjoy Roman citizenship expands as
well so by 88 BC all of Italy is holds
Roman citizenship and by 212 AD
everybody in the Roman Empire from
Britain to Sudan from Iraq to Morocco
holds Roman citizenship to be fair we
have to mention you know slaves did not
get vote well and women didn't get their
women to get to vote were there races
that didn't get to vote even but they
just were given Roman citizen no and
it's not a concept that didn't exist
then back then there are concepts like
that yeah
but generally speaking Romans didn't
feel that there's any that they said
were racial differences and they saw
ethnic differences and they said
Geographic differences but they didn't
see racial differences in the way that
say someone in the 19th century United
States would see racial differences and
they didn't feel that anybody of a
certain racial background or geographic
background should be excluded from
citizenship just because this is their
background and so there were people in
North Africa for example who would get a
vote in the Roman Republic in not in the
Roman Republic
not many yeah citizenship really comes
to North Africa and in large quantities
in the late 2nd and early 3rd centuries
but it was a time of expansion for Rome
right even before the Empire the
Republic kept you know getting more and
more territory under its purview yes
yeah and what the Republic is able to do
and what leaders of the Republic are
able to do is they recognize that even
in this period I mean really a feature
of the Empire that Rome starts
incorporating large numbers of people
from places like Greece and North Africa
but even in the Republic there was an
idea that extending citizenship to
individuals who are useful you know
prominent people government people this
was something you know that made some
sense
I mean Caesar would do this in in Gaul
for example where prominent Gallic
chieftains would would get Roman
citizenship and they would take a Roman
name and so you have these in these
family inscriptions in Gaul where you
have somebody who has crazy Gallic name
and then they're their son is Julius
Caesar crazy Gallic name and then
they're you know the son of that person
is just a nice Roman name the
inscriptions in Latin and it
commemorates this transition from
completely not Roman to Roman citizen to
somebody who doesn't really see much
difference between himself and somebody
living in the city of earlier very good
assimilators
part of their genius they're very good
at this yeah and okay so a couple of
hundred years of successful life as a
republic in Rome and part of it was the
sort of gradual deliberate consensus
based approach I mean there's a lot more
inertia built into the system
intentionally in the Roman Republic than
versus Athenian democracy as you say but
then we hit a trouble spot in around 130
BC and with the story of the croc ease
and I yeah I'll confessed I had never
heard the story before starting reading
your book and then digging into the
details but it's such a fascinating
story why he tell us about these two
brothers starting with Tiberius I guess
was the first one right yeah so there's
these are two brothers Tiberius Gracchus
and then his brother Gaius Krakus and
Tiberius is the older brother by quite a
bit and Tiberius comes from a family
that is in essence if the Kennedys
married the bushes you know this is the
bluest blood most rebel rouser from the
streets
no no he's somebody who's well-placed to
do really well in political life and
he's incredibly skilled a wonderful
Order someone who is very good at
building personal relationships and also
somebody with a distinguished military
career I remember there was a line in
your book that I didn't actually bring a
copy of the book so I can't quote it but
I loved it because it reminds us this is
ancient Rome not modern United States
you know he came from this incredibly
establishment family and he was trained
in philosophy and oratory to you know
succeed in politics that's not what we
do these days or politicians no no I
didn't it is something that is a useful
tool and even in the Roman Republic
there are people who did this in people
who didn't but what Tiberius Gracchus
understood was these are tools that can
be deployed in certain contexts and be
deployed very usefully and he understood
not only how to use rhetoric but when to
use rhetoric and so he is a person who
is on the fast track to being a really
prominent Roman politician but a really
prominent establishment Roman politician
and in the course of one of his junior
offices he is a holding a position more
or less whole managing the books in a
campaign in Spain and the campaign goes
drastically wrong in the
have captured and siberius Caracas
negotiates the surrender agreement and
the the liberation of the Roman captives
but when they come back to the city of
Rome
there's people on the other side of the
political divide you start demagoguing
this and saying that well Romans don't
surrender and Romans don't negotiate and
if you surrender your life is forfeit
and this is a principle that Romans
abstractly believed but it's not one
that Romans really like to put to the
test but from an objective point of view
it seems that the negotiation that
Tiberius did was actually pretty
successful it was quite successful yet
yeah he got the entire army out and in
return he had to agree agree basically
to a peace treaty that was not favorable
to Rome but he saved tens of thousands
of life I gave back some of the loot
that they had plundered right okay so
yeah let's do that and save the lives of
and and so he comes home and people in
the Senate who are conservative and are
looking for an issue to really attack
not even Tiberius but the commander who
was responsible for this say that this
this can't be done you know you were
Romans we can't we can't negotiate we
give them the go to Oteri's yeah we
can't make this kind of concession to
people who are less than us and Tiberius
gets kind of caught in the middle it's
not really about him but the families of
the soldiers the Tiberius managed to
liberate rally around him and the effort
to completely undo this peace agreement
falters because there's so much popular
pressure that in the end they send the
commander back and they let the army
stay but everybody remembered what
Tiberius had done you know that Tiberius
had shown up this establishment push to
punish what seemed like a completely
anti Roman type of behavior and so this
is remembered and Tiberius understands
this and he's remembered by people and
political power who have control and
sent some sense over his future
political career yeah this is remembered
by the establishment and Tiberius --is
first act was as an establishment figure
he's not one anymore
and so what Tiberius realizes is if he
wants to have a future political career
and he done well but he hadn't done as
well as his family expected and he
hadn't done as well as previous
generations had and that's a problem in
a Roman context you know if you don't do
as well politically as your father did
your failed I mean you you have failed
and it looks badly for you it looks
badly for your children and so Tiberius
has to make a decision of about whether
he's going to step back and potentially
not advance any further politically or
if he's going to in a sense lean in to
this populist persona that he's fallen
into by accident right so he has the
support of all these families who are
not highly politically correct and
connected but he that wasn't his
constituency but those are the people
who were on his side right now and
they're very enthusiastic and in the
soldiers whose lives he saves you know
they're back in Rome they're citizens
they can vote they're very enthusiastic
as well and so he leans into this and he
begins crafting a second act that is as
a populist and there's a lot of things
for him to run on what had happened
after Hannibal's invasion of Italy and
the Roman victory in the second Punic
War was a massive rebuilding of Italy if
it benefited everybody but in the
context of this there's a financial
revolution that grows out of the massive
amount of government contracts that are
now coming into coming into being people
have to bid in advance for these and if
the contracts are for things like
mineral extraction you bid you pay in
advance and then you go and extract the
minerals and if you can get more that's
your profit I mean if you get less too
bad for you nobody has that kind of
money and so what ends up happening very
quickly is people take out loans who
want to want to work on these contracts
and roman's realize that you could
figure out the likelihood that that loan
is going to be repaid look at the
percentage that's likely to be repaid
and the amount of profit that's likely
to come in and that meant the loan had
value you know if you could figure out
the likelihood this is going to be
repaid you can assess the value and then
you can sell it this is very modern
yeah Concepcion long before Adam Smith
but it's very capitalist in finding
exactly exactly and if you sell it then
you can recapitalize and you can do it
again derivative trading yeah and so for
the first 50 years or so of the second
century you have a situation where
everybody's boats are floating
everybody's boat everybody's tide is
rising poor people are rebuilding Italy
rich people are developing these
mechanisms to generate wealth very very
quickly but around 140 it slows down for
poor people but it doesn't slow down for
rich people and what Tiberius Gracchus
realizes is there's a perception problem
here poor people are not becoming
ridiculously poor but they're not going
to do as well as their parents did rich
people continue to get richer and richer
and richer and Tiberius Gracchus runs
for the office of Tribune of the plebs
which is a an election elected office
that allows you to propose laws to
plebeians
but Tribune's tend to be more I suppose
radical that can be more radical than
people who are elected to offices that
will put them in the Senate and what
Tiberius realizes is he could run his
Tribune of the plebs and he could
propose economic reforms and there will
be a constituency for this right there
are people who really feel that the
situation is is imbalanced the Republic
is not doing enough to fix this and
Tiberius has space to use the popular
following he has to propose some
solutions to this initially he wins
election and initially he proposes a lot
that's very similar to a law that had
been proposed before and senatorial
forces and conservative forces and rich
people say this isn't good enough for us
you know he wants to redistribute a
certain amount of land and compensate
the people who were renting this public
land it wasn't taking any private land
at all it wasn't there even it was
already a law saying this should happen
and he just kind of wanted to enforce it
there was that a bit too strong yeah so
there's there's a tremendous amount of
public land that the Roman Republic had
taken from cities that had rebelled
under Hannibal and it's just they didn't
know what to do with it some of it they
gave to Roman citizens but some of it
they they
least out - landholders many of them
Italian and so therefore they don't have
a say in what's going on in Roman
politics but there was supposed to be a
limit of there's not possible ona how
much you could have a wealth cap which
these days would not even be discussed
yeah I mean it would be like if you had
restrictions on the amount of land that
you could graze in Nevada per person
yeah and everybody could only grace 300
acres of land and somebody starts
grazing 600 acres
you can either enforce it or you can
decide it's not worth enforcing and for
much of the second century Romans
decided this isn't really worth
enforcing what was proposed by by an
earlier politician and Reid sort of
rejuvenated by Tiberius caucus was to
take people who had land in excess of
the limit and just take away the excess
land that was public that they didn't
own and compensate them for the loss of
this land that they had been leasing and
then give that land people who were
Roman who didn't have land to farm and
this is a pretty moderate proposal but
it's not something that there could yet
be a consensus around and so it's how
various Caracas and and to remind
ourselves you know the whole point of
the Republic and how it worked is that
you move slowly right and you build
consensus and the ship of state is very
stately yeah you don't want to do
anything that's going to upset that's
going to upset a large number of people
and even if it is something that
benefits a lot of people if there's not
enough support for it that you can build
enough of a consensus that people will
allow it to go through it probably ought
not to go through because people will
resist it and normally if you have a
proposal and you can't build consensus
for it you either try to negotiate a
compromise or you let it drop and the
earlier proposal like this the person
who proposed it decided to let it drop
he couldn't build a consensus he
couldn't find any compromises that would
work so he let it drop Tiberius caucus
decides not to let it drop but instead
he realizes that he has this rhetorical
ability that's incredible he has this
this fervent support amongst
parts of the population and he's not
gonna waste that and so what he does is
he pushes into this space this ambiguous
space between what you traditionally did
and what you could do yeah and he starts
doing everything that he could do so
there wasn't a law against what he was
doing but people hadn't done it you're
not supposed to do it and he said well
stop me
he said yeah so so make it stop so he
proposes the law and each of the
tribunes when a law is proposed to have
a veto over this one of them who is
working with the Senate exercises his
veto this is perfectly proper because
the the way that informally the Senate
and the patricians influenced what
happened in a plebeian assembly was they
had a Tribune who they would communicate
with and say this isn't gonna fly the
Senate will take an opinion on one of
these laws and usually that's enough but
if the Senate says we don't think this
is a good law and someone wants to push
it forward a Tribune who will work with
the Senate will veto it and that will
end it
so Tiberius is laws vetoed and Tiberius
brings his mob of supporters and deposes
the Tribune who vetoed it and the mob of
supporters is not violent but they are
threatening and they're loud that sounds
a little you know extra procedural there
right yeah it's it's what he did is not
illegal yeah but it was done under
conditions that seemed intimidating even
the mob deposing the guy is not illegal
Tiberius but Tiberius his idea which
again probably is influenced to some
degree by what he had read in Greek
philosophy his idea was that the people
are the ultimate empowering agent and so
all legitimacy in the Roman state
resides with the people and if the
people decide they wanted to pose a
magistrate they're exercising legitimate
political power and this is an idea that
no one in Rome had ever endorsed this is
Athenian democracy channeled through the
structures of the Roman Republic and
Romans did not like that
and Romans generally would have resisted
that except it's really scary you know
come into this assembly and it's it's
really scary and Sirte bearest opposes
the Tribune and
Tiberius gets his law passed the Senate
objects to this but the law is binding
on everybody and so then the Senate has
the bet the power to not fund the law
because the one power that the Senate
indisputably has is allocating money for
things and to do this kind of land
reform you need surveyors and you need
people who will provide equipment to the
new farmers and you need all sorts of
things to make this happen and the
Senate controls all of the money that
can make all of those things possible
this part I thought was hilarious will
let you have your law and your
Commission but you have no money to do
anything with it yeah yeah I mean it's
and we see things like this I love yeah
and so Tiberius then has this tremendous
act of fortune because the king who's in
charge of a kingdom in what's now Turkey
dies and in his will he leaves the
entire kingdom to the Roman people now
the Senate another thing that it
controls another one of the few things
that controls is Foreign Affairs and so
this is seen as a foreign action giving
his kingdom to the Roman people that's
something the Senate should deal with
Tiberius says we'll wait a second the
voice of the people is now channeled
through all these agencies and the voice
of the people matters and so you can't
just say oh we're the Senate we
represent you know we represent Rome
that will says the Roman people the
Roman people will speak and so he brings
forward a motion saying all of the money
in this kingdoms Treasury should go to
fund the Land Commission and their
people and the concilium plebis they
vote for those yeah and Tiberius gets
his money for his Land Commission and
again it's not illegal what he did but
it's not done yeah and then Tiberius
decides he's not really finished there's
probably going to be some problems for
him and when he leaves office he doesn't
have any prospect to run for higher
office quite yet and so he decides to
stand again for the office of Tribune of
the plebs this again is not illegal but
it wasn't done and so when the voting
starts
Tiberius has his mob of supporters who
are intimidating people and threatening
people and senators who are opposed to
him have had enough now Maurice has
never used violence and this is I think
an important thing he is not the one who
brings violence like actual physical
violence into the Roman political arena
but he's used intimidation quite a bit
and so when he's standing for
re-election opponents bring in a mob and
then the mob actually uses physical
violence and kills Tiberius Gracchus
that's the first incident the first
violent incident in more than 300 years
and what was thankfully the Senate or
yeah it was it was completely the the
actual physical violence came from
Tiberius his opponents and he's a victim
of it yeah
but the conditions that established you
know the the things that made it
possible to imagine that this would be
necessary where conditions of Tiberius
had said can we judge his personal
sincerity in his reform efforts was he
like really devoted to the people or did
he think that was a politically
expedient tactic I think it's both I
think he's I think he's devoted to the
people but I think he's also very aware
that this is useful to him right I mean
it's a complicated legacy because he's a
reformer he's some kind of you know
socialist Democrat whatever you know
trying to give land back to the people
which maybe that's a good thing but like
you say I mean maybe the most important
part of his legacy is that he violated
these norms and that shook down through
the years yeah I think the important
thing to keep in mind when we're talking
about this reform and Tiberius Gracchus
has this historical legacy where a lot
of people especially on the Left feel
he's a you know a proto Marxist or a
proto leftist hero if that reform had
gone through and he had redistributed
all over the land it's estimated he
probably would have settled about 26,000
families and the population in Italy at
this time is about four million yeah
it's it's you know it's not
insignificant but it's not going to
solve the problem it's not a radical
solution and it's public property that
he's giving so he's not redistributing
wealth in any
way he's not taking private property in
any meaningful way he's not doing
anything to attack these people who are
the new 1% that are generating all of
this money really fast this is a modest
reform and what's radical is just the
way he pushed it and I mean I do want to
- maybe there should be for later but I
we don't want to say that any norm
braking is bad right like in some sense
you have the American Revolution the
French Revolution we took up arms
against a monarchy and we think the
American Revolution in any case worked
out pretty well but you would like to
make the argument that this was not the
time or place to violate those norms of
governance yeah I think the Republic
would have gotten where he wanted them
to get it wasn't that big a thing and he
didn't invent this idea it would have
gotten there it but his name wouldn't
have been attached to it right and I
think the big problem for tiberias
Krakus is he wanted his name attached to
it he wanted the policy but he wanted
his name attached to it as well well
there's a selection effect successful
politicians are ambitious but yeah
construction right and then he had a
younger brother who in some sense tried
to follow in his footsteps
his younger brother I think is one of
the the true genuine heroes of this
whole period yeah because he knew what
he was getting into Gaius this is Gaius
he knew he would die you know he knew
that what happened Tiberias would happen
to him yeah we should remember the
stakes are pretty high here people died
well yeah you know the things went wrong
yeah and he knew that he couldn't use
intimidation and threats in the way his
brother did because immediately the
reaction would be he should die gays
were told has a dream before he even
goes into politics he has a dream that's
he will die you know he's going to
pursue this legacy and he will die and
they believed in prophecies it at that
time and he's dead right yeah and that
one came true so what he does is he he
thinks our area imagines a reform
program that will genuinely make a
difference it's a reform program that
includes giving subsidized food to the
population in the city of Rome it
includes establishing colonies in places
like the city of Carthage that Rome had
destroyed in 146 BC but is
really really good location and he he
proposed again Landry distributions and
reactivating the commission that his
brother had set up and in a way that
that foresaw the future he proposed the
extensions of citizenships to everybody
in Italy and he genuinely wanted these
things to happen and that last movement
is a important one I think if we do want
to draw parallels to today because in
some sense they're populist steg rocky
brothers right the other they're getting
their support from a wide base but but
Gaius wanted to expand the who counts as
Roman right there which is it sort of
anti typical populist move yeah and that
and he had a lot of there was a lot of
pushback the reason that games wanted to
do this is because this economic and
wealth inequality in Italy wasn't just
felt by Romans it was also felt by
Italians and a lot of the people who
were in the lower lower classes and
we're feeling like they didn't have
opportunities to have us a big a farm as
their parents they started coming to the
cities and especially to the city of
Rome and so the city of Rome that was
probably a little more than a hundred
thousand people and 200 BC by the time
of Augustus is a million and a lot of
these people came starting in the middle
part of the second century and a lot of
them were Roman citizens which meant
they could be in the city of Rome but a
lot of them weren't Roman citizens a lot
of them were Italians who moved to the
city of Rome without citizenship status
and were working there and about three
years before Gaius raucous holds office
politicians in Rome staged an arrest and
deportation of these Italians who don't
belong in the city of Rome it's the
first time this was done it's not the
last time it would be done and so what
Gaius actually saw was a policy that was
a good policy politically not so good a
policy you know the non Roman citizens
can't vote for him so it's not gonna get
him any votes immediately now if they
become citizens it could vote for him
but in the short term this isn't a
winning policy for him but it's a it's a
problem that needs to be
solved and his policy was a
problem-solving solution that in many
ways foresaw that this was only going to
get worse right but it did not work out
well for gays no no we Gaius I think
understood full well what this would
mean
and because Gaius really did play by the
rules you know he didn't do the sorts of
shenanigans his brother did the first
year that Gaius is in office is really
successful because no one really thinks
no one can block him there's consensus
around his ideas and there's a general
net a general sense that he's genuine in
pursuing these things and so the he's
not looking to potentially take over the
state or some of the things that people
feared Tiberius was doing he's solving
problems and so he runs for re-election
and the second term that he has his
opponents make the interesting decision
to in effect outbid him and so he
proposes citizenship for Italians they
propose more you know he proposes a
colony they propose more colonies and
they eat away at his support by in a
modern context or a modern sense moving
to the left of him right and he then
becomes not radical enough in his
solutions robbing him from the left yeah
and it's it's genius
because he ends up losing support and
then they stage an outbreak of violence
and he's wrapped up in it and he's
assassinated and none of the other
reforms that were trying to outflank him
to the left ever come to anything they
were just political tactics and so Gaius
is I think one of the few I think
unmitigated and and unquestionable
heroes in the late Republican period
because he knew exactly what he was
getting into
he knew how this would end and but still
it was a hundred years
before the Republic actually went away
it wasn't as if you know that the next
day it collapsed so what how do you is
it fair to trace these moves by the
grothy brothers to the ultimate decline
of the Republic yes for a couple of
reasons I think what what Tiberius
Gracchus does is he shows that norm
breaking is a political tool
it's a useful political tool and it's
one that if you go too far you will
probably be punished severely but if you
can figure out how to do it so that it
you get what you want but you don't
alarm people so much that they feel like
you have to be killed it's very useful
yeah the other thing is the use of
violence against Gaius also becomes
something of a political tool it's again
something where it's becoming normal
enough that if you can use violence
against people that our opponents you
can't otherwise work with and you're not
directly involved it's okay
you know it's useful there was a new
norm where a little bit it might makes
right yeah and people begin
experimenting with ways to do this so
that it works but there's no blowback
because there's tremendous blowback
against the people who killed the kuraki
but by 100 people are figuring out how
to do this by say arming a mob of
supporters all the time that you can
then call out and they can make
demonstrations and they can attack
supporters of other people and you can
intimidate politicians without directly
attacking politicians sometimes it gets
out of control but you enter into this
cycle where something explodes there's
an act of violence everybody says this
is horrible
there's a retrenchment a new new status
quo is established it holds for a little
while and brahmins begin to think oh the
republic is back and it's stable and
we're past this point where there's so
much friction and tension and then it
starts up again and i think that the
story that starts with the Gracchi is
this the cyclical story of political
dysfunction violence a settling of you
know a settling of the the system for a
little while maybe a decade maybe a
generation everybody kind of gets used
to the fact that there are now rules
that govern this and they begin to take
for granted the fact that the Republic
is stable and people start playing these
games again violating norms to push
their own personal agendas and
ultimately getting back to another
crisis and to put ourselves in there
shoes you know we think of the American
Revolution 200 years ago as really long
ago right and to these Romans the
Republic had been around for four
hundred years already which must must
their history was not as good there yet
their record-keeping that just seemed
like forever I presume
yeah idea that there wouldn't be
Republic it just wouldn't appear to them
probably and I think the other thing
that's important for us to do is to
actually live this in their time you
know a day is a day and so if something
happened ten years ago that seems like a
long time ago and when something is
happening in a cycle that repeats every
25 years say it's perfectly reasonable
to think when you're in the middle of
that cycle if your republic is 400 years
old yeah okay it's back it's back to
normal it's okay it's stable and you
don't realize that this is unfolding not
on a timeline of a year or five years
but it's unfolding on a timeline of like
a hundred years which is impossible for
human beings really care about now and
and so your sense of history is what you
can remember in effect and I think the
other thing that's important is when you
look at the demographic charts for
Romans I mean it's pretty it's pretty
dire but if you make it past five years
old you have a very good chance of
making it to 50 yeah but then once you
get to 50 the cliff really starts
appearing that's true it's still true
today I'm feeling it so I get it yeah so
I I feel it too but what that means is
if you have a cycle that you know the
violence's is starting when you're in
your 20s and then it settles down when
you're about 25 and then you have a good
12 or 15 years where yeah it looks like
it looks like you understand how things
are happening it looks like things have
settled down and this would be say you
know after Gaius Krakus there's this
period of retrenchment by a few
aristocratic families who then more or
less dominate the state for about 15
years okay if you're 25 when Gaius
Krakus dies you're 40 when that starts
breaking down and you're 50 by the time
there's an
they're burst of really serious violence
you're dead you know the people who are
experiencing this in when when violence
breaks out again around 100 most of them
don't remember the Gracchi you know
their political experience is of
stability and this general decline in
the same way that you know Millennials
who lived through the recent government
shutdown don't remember the Gingrich
government shutdown right because they
were five years old but also this brings
up a question I've had about you know
where the information and knowledge
comes from I presume that most Romans
are not literate I don't know I mean
just not news payers but do they have
books or is it just all oral tradition
where they learn about things from the
past
so the literacy question is a really
good one I think based on what we have
in Pompeii we can say that it's not it's
certainly not say like a modern society
where it approaches a hundred percent
but it's not as bad as you would think
either I think what you see in Pompeii
is people of all social classes can read
you know from slaves all the way and
prostitutes all the way up to the most
elite people who have libraries the
percentage is really hard to gauge but
some functional literacy on some level
is probably pushing 50 percent so that's
Varys but reading histories is probably
one percent how was news passed around
were there proclamations in the square
or you know there's there's graffiti
there's there are laws that are posted
there are inscriptions that the dictate
dictate ideas or policies there's a lot
of written material all over the place
and I think what's interesting in this
context is election campaigns a lot of
the electioneering there are you know
placards and there are you Griff
electoral related graffiti and we know
this mainly from Pompeii but in Pompeii
even deep in the Empire I mean Pompeii
the eruption is around 80 AD so you're
already more than a hundred years into
the empire there's still local elections
going on in Pompeii and you can see the
way campaigning tends to work and so I
think that there is a general sense of
what someone stands for when they
campaign and how they fit into a larger
trajectory and there's also I think
lived memory of who somebody is and what
they represent but the history the
understanding of the past is really I
think going to be something where what
you've lived through is going to feel
much more immediate than anything before
that and there is a real challenge in
Roman history especially you don't
really have any kind of narrative
histories written by Romans until the
time of Hannibal right and so all of
this stuff from the early republic and
from the royal period it's it's
circulating what it's circulating his
stories yeah and these stories tend to
take on the the tenor of morality tales
and so when you're understanding
contemporary events you are mixing say
if you're living in the year 100 the
Gracchi
with these figures from the 5th century
and with Roman kings and and you're
listen rivas yeah and you're importing
virtue into you know virtue from these
deep traditions into what the grotty are
doing and I think that also leads to you
missing the real kind of progression
that you're living through yeah and so
you made the point about the sort of
time scale of eruptions of violence and
so forth and but there's also I don't
know whether its economic or
socio-political changes where more and
more power in armies was associated with
individuals rather than with the state
yeah and then and this is something that
comes out of that period in the 110s
where that stability under these elite
families it ends in large part because
these elite families become quite
corrupt which is not not surprisingly
post-event yeah and so what ends up
happening is there's a figure who runs
against this a man named Marius and the
he does this in the context of a Roman
war with a North African kingdom that
Rome should have won easily but was
really struggling to fight effectively
and he runs against the commander who
belongs to the most elite and most
established of these families that had
dominated political life for the last
decade and runs against him as corrupt
and ineffectual and neither one of those
things was actually true but it makes
for you know it's the lone
it's the moment to do that and so when
he wins election he has to build an army
and everybody feels like Rome is
exhausted and he's not going to find
troops and generally speaking when
Romans raised armies they tended to only
bring people into the army who had
property above a certain level and what
Marius understood was he probably isn't
gonna get an army if he has to live
within those means so what he decides to
do is raise an army with any volunteer
who's willing to serve and all of a
sudden he gets a very very enthusiastic
and loyal army that he takes to North
Africa they win the war and then he wins
a series of elections to use this and
other armies to confront German
barbarians to the north because we
should say back in those days the I mean
people are enthusiastic join the army in
part because they thought that was a
route to looting and riches right it
could be there's a couple things you get
out of it and one is if you win the
campaign there's lots of stuff that you
can get and lots of loot and riches that
you can take home but there's also a
sense that the Republic might reward you
yeah
and Marius is soldiers in particular
come to believe that they've done such a
good job and they don't have property so
the Republic should provide them with
property and what Marius ends up doing
is working with allies to secure a
retirement package for his soldiers when
his term of office is up and this is
this is wonderful but what it means
effectively is every other commander now
has to do the same thing and every other
commander now has armies that realize
that their retirement package their
discharge bonus basically is going to
depend on the political fortunes of the
guy who recruited them and so eventually
again now you have a new variable that
is illegal you you can't use your army
to march on Rome to get these things but
you can have your army show up and look
angry but brandish a spear or two yeah
it's heavy your sprocket style right you
can you can use the the threat that they
might do this
as a political tool and people start
doing this and in the end
there is a commander in the 80s who
feels like this this is the commander
Scylla he feels like he actually needs
to make use of the tool it's not threats
but it's actually marching the army on
Rome and so that does this and the
troops are willing to do this because
for 15 years from Marius to SOLAS march
on Rome this has just become part of
what troops expect you know you're loyal
to your commander you're serving the
state but your loyalty is to your
commander he's the one who's gonna
provide the goods and the minute your
commanders not loyal to the state he
could ask you to choose and no one had
asked anyone to choose until Scylla
but once Scylla asks them to choose this
again is a political tool and it's a
political tool that lots of people will
use yeah and so over and over again you
get this thing where there's something
that just isn't done until someone does
it because that's what their incentives
are and then once it's done the
floodgates are open yeah but again the
pacing is important right the floodgates
are open in that someone else can do
this but they generally don't you know
they they know it's been done but it's
not like well Scylla does it and then
it's done again because that's a solo
provokes a civil war but after that
Civil War calms down nobody really does
this again someone tries it in the 77
tries it in the 60s but no one actually
does it for real until Caesar yeah and
this is in 48 Julius eats really is yeah
but once it was done it was in the
vocabulary of things you could do and
that meant that there could come a
moment where somebody would say let's do
it again
yeah it doesn't happen immediately again
I mean when you're in this when you're
in this world most of the time people
aren't thinking that this is possible
they know sulla did it but they don't
think it's possible that it will happen
again because there's no sign for you
know for years that anything like this
could happen again the pounds we get to
40 or 50 BC then we have Caesar and
Pompey and others and they have their
armies and they're very ambitious yeah
yeah and in Caesars case you know the
the civil war that undoes the
for many effectively undoes the Republic
when the one that really undoes the
Republic is Augustus his work but what
with Caesar and Pompey the situation is
is one that plays out on a bunch of
different levels Caesar and Pompey had
been allies and Caesar had commanded an
army and conquered what's now basically
France half of Switzerland all of
Belgium and part of the Netherlands
invaded Britain and pulled back I will
put in a plug by the way Dane Carlton's
hardcore history I don't know if you
know this podcast but he does a
wonderful podcast and he has like six
hours on Caesar's campaigns in Gaul oh
wow well worth listening to
oh yeah and so Caesar Caesar does all of
this with an army that is a very serious
and very powerful army but the war is
probably illegal and so Caesar
negotiates for much of the last part of
the 50s BC to try to figure out how he
can be reincorporated into Roman
political life because conquering this
much territory means Caesar is
incredibly wealthy he has really really
good troops who are really loyal to him
and he needs to figure out terms under
which he can come back into Roman
political life and not be punished for
this in a bit naughty but he's really
powerful yeah and and Romans are really
scared of him at least elite Romans are
really scared of him regular Romans are
really enthusiastic about him and so
he's not a figure who easily fits in a
Republican structure and Pompey begins
working with Caesars opponents first to
try to negotiate something but
ultimately as a as a champion who could
potentially confront Caesar if he needed
to what ends up happening is the
negotiations break down and Caesar
realizes that he will probably die if he
doesn't attack Rome the Republic can't
protect him and whatever promises
anybody is making for legal protections
and legal due process and immunity those
can easily be undone and there's no
political structure that can prevent
that from happening so there's a lot of
weight that goes on this so I just want
to see how certain we are or whether
this is the kind of thing Caesar would
have said after the fact I mean so he's
a
credibly successful campaigner
throughout what we call Europe now so he
has a big army like he they have really
really good soldiers and the people in
power in Rome itself and the
establishment are afraid of him and
don't like him and so what is his
evidence that he can't just go back like
that the norms have been so violated or
are so fragile that even though he's
been very successful he would be his
life would be in danger if he returned
to Rome so for Caesar the things that
would be reassuring for him if you could
go back to Italy and stand for office
while his army is with him that's okay
because then he's protected they can't
do anything to him because they have to
confront his army that's not allowed so
then he says can I stand for office in
absentia because if he stands for office
he can't be prosecuted if he stands for
office in absentia he can get elected
and he said if I get elected I will come
back and I'll dismiss my army before I
go that's not okay either what they want
he's told that that's not okay he's told
that's not and that raises his
suspicions and that I think that makes
perfect sense and so what what he would
he then you know what he then is sort of
promised as well you can come back and
you can stand for office and it will be
you know you can stand for office and if
you're elected it will be like a month
before you take office and and that
should be okay but what had happened
across the 50s as the elections have
been delayed all the time people had
organized violence to prevent elections
from happening and so just because you
have an election date that you can stand
in doesn't mean that election will
actually happen and I think Caesars
worry is he would go back he would be
told that he could stand for election
those were the terms the son had offered
if he released his army and agreed to
stand for election his command over that
army would lapse before he actually was
elected and before he took office and
then someone were prosecuted and so for
Caesar this looks like the the Senate is
dealing in bad faith before the Senate
it looks like Caesar is angling to try
to be in a position where he can use
violence against Rome if the election
doesn't go his way and so both sides I
think legitimately have concerns neither
one of them trusts
the Republic is going to be functional
enough to allow a compromise on the
terms of you know law and precedent but
from that telling it sounds very
plausible that Caesar wasn't sort of he
would have been happy
perhaps staying within the Republican
framework if he thought that his
personal safety and wealth could be
guaranteed yeah I mean I think we go
back to this original point of what the
Republic is the Republic is a mechanism
that guarantees the political conflict
is going to be peaceful and everybody
who enters into it into a political
contest knows what they'll win and what
they'll lose and in the context of
Caesar confronting Pompey and the Senate
Caesar would prefer this to be a
peaceful political contest when the
civil war starts I think it's not likely
that Caesar is going to win but I think
Caesars calculation is if I don't do
this and I march back to Rome I I will
be punished for sure
yeah and if I just stay in Gaul and
refuse to march back to Rome and refuse
to dismiss my army Pompey will assemble
a massive army from all of the other
territory Rome controls and he'll
destroy me and so in some sense the
legacy of the previous hundred years
since the gruffy brothers is that on
when stakes get high if you lose in the
political arena you die yeah yeah and
this is the lesson that starts with
Tiberius Caracas the rules for political
contests had been set by the Republic
for over 300 years you knew what
happened if you won you knew what
happened if you lost
and after Tiberius Caracas didn't really
know what would happen if you lost and
you also didn't really know what the
rules of the conflict would be what the
rules of the contest would be somebody
could change them in the middle and what
do you do then and there's no guarantee
at the end that what you thought would
be the worst possible outcome is
actually the worst possible outcome
something much worse could happen so we
had the civil war and Caesar wins and
Caesar went and what happens Caesar has
to figure out what he's going to do and
he has a few models I mean one model is
what sulla had done in Sola had marched
on Rome he had won a civil war he had
himself proclaimed dictator but sulla
was very old
and Scylla also understood that probably
this wasn't going to be a sustainable
position for him so Scylla reworked the
Roman Constitution and then stepped down
as dictator and retired and he died
copiers later that wasn't gonna work for
Caesar because he was young and so when
Caesar won the Civil War he couldn't
just reform the Republican step down he
was gonna potentially live for another
15 years and it's quite possible that
whatever he set up if he's not there to
superintendent could go south and he's
still there to be prosecuted or punished
or killed so that wasn't feasible and he
needed to figure out what sort of
structure would actually work a monarchy
wouldn't rome had gotten rid of a
monarchy and so caesar played with that
idea a little bit and realized that
Romans wouldn't accept that and so
ultimately when Caesar comes up with is
a a structure where he's a dictator
forever and the regular offices of the
Republic resume but Caesar picks all the
people who will have these offices and
so at the time of Caesar's assassination
there's a list of people who will hold
offices for the next few years and
everybody knew where they were on that
list and Caesars idea was if you have
somebody who knows in three years
they're gonna have an office they really
want they won't make trouble well I've
been in the game yeah yeah and so what
ends up happening is Brutus and Cassius
end up happening but Caesar it wasn't as
if he marched in with his army and just
you know said I'm the Emperor right I
mean he he did try to gradually you know
work within the remit run into the
Republican system yeah what Caesar was
trying to do was in effect make the
Republic start up again with Caesar
protected as dictator and one of the
things that Caesar realized was there
are a lot of reforms that he could
institute that would be popular and so
Caesar worked on this this high level
and then the government officials did
more or less what they did you know the
people who regulated whether the markets
were effectively way engrained fairly
they still did what they did Caesar
didn't do that and it was a popular
system with the people of Rome right I
mean it wasn't as if they were like no
no we don't want a dictator or a
republic yeah there was and this is
another thing where we might draw a
lessons for modern societies but the
idea of a strong leader taking care of
us was something that a lot of people
bought into right and the other thing is
the their elections
I mean Cesar's picking who's running but
there are elections and so you still
still have elections you still have
offices but Caesars just there making
sure everything is working as it should
and when Caesar wasn't there things
sometimes didn't work like they should
and they would fix they would just serve
right themselves only when Caesar showed
up in Rome but what was distasteful just
people like Brutus and Cassius wasn't
ideal of Liberty that they felt like
they needed to restore and what's
intriguing about this is this is Brutus
is political brand Bertus issues coins
in 54 BC that say liberty' Libra
thoughts on them and they have Lady
Liberty the personification of Libertas
Libertas on the front of the coin and on
the back they say Brutus
that's his brand but Brutus is brand in
54 BC was Liberty is about following the
laws that the people set up you know if
the people set up and people say that
this is this is what's legal and this is
the policy then that's the policy and
tyranny is people for an individual
exercising power that is not legal that
the people don't give them and do we
think that in the I know it's hard to
read people's minds but do we think that
Brutus's motivations are really pretty
much idealistic in the sense even when
he's assassinating Caesar for sure but
what's interesting is his idea of
Liberty libertas has changed Libre toss
in 54 was the laws you know the laws
dictate how society should run tyranny
is not following the laws the laws said
Caesar is dictator the laws said Caesar
has this power the law is all said that
this structure that Caesar put in place
was legal and Brutus then has to say
wait this is one man in charge and
that's tyranny but that's the office
of what tyranny was to him in 54 and so
so Brutus has to make this jump that
another one it makes complete sense and
on the other hand makes no sense in
ideological II there's an issue with
what Libertas is to Brutus and 44 and
this is an issue that plays out after
the assassination of Caesar Brutus kills
Caesar Brutus expects to immediately be
held as this champion of Liberty was
restored freedom to the Romans and
instead everybody panics and the whole
city is sort of scared to death of
what's gonna come next and Brutus is
shocked people didn't actually like what
Brutus was promising them it took an
extra day for virtus to even deliver the
speech he'd planned in that time people
loyal to Caesar had crafted their own
response so one of them who is the
military commander under Caesar while
Caesar was alive organizes the military
forces just outside of the city of Rome
comes in occupies part of the forum
Mark Antony figures out how to work
rhetorically to craft a legacy for
Caesar that will be popular and
ultimately on the second day after the
assassination the Senate has to agree to
ratify all of Caesars acts when Antony
comes in and says you realize if you
condemned him as a tyrant like Brutus
wants you to all of these offices that
you held under Caesar are illegal and
all of these offices Caesar promised to
you they'll that'll be canceled
and so caesar's gambit of incorporating
these people by giving them stuff secure
caesar's legacy he can't be attacked as
a tyrant and Brutus agrees to this
because Brutus was one of the people who
had benefited from this we're deep into
Shakespeare play territory now yeah and
it makes perfect sense like this but
you'd look at the history of course
Shakespeare would write about this
because it's very Shakespearean as it
were but but yeah and so I mean maybe we
know a little bit about how things go
there's a whole bunch of civil wars back
and forth right yeah and I mean so
Antony gets an alliance magnet does he
marry Cleopatra do they ever get married
or
well he's married to Octavian's sister
I'm not sure officially in Roman eyes
what that relationship is okay yes
children with her it's clear that this
is the marriage that this is the
relationship that really matters to him
but I don't know for sure whether he
divorces Octavia or not and if so when
okay there was a lot of politicking
where was the Gustus at this time when
okay Octavia at the time so she was
being sassy he's a fascinating figure
he's 19 years old he appears on the list
of people that Caesar was going to give
an office in the future he is in the
city of Apollonia which is in Albania
now it's at the end of the Via Ignatieff
so for those of you are Byzantine
history fans this is the road this is
the main street of the Byzantine Empire
it starts in Constantinople and it runs
all the way to Apollonia and it's the
road that links the Salonika in
Constantinople so it's the most
important road across the Balkans and
Caesar had planned
once the campaigning season and the
sailing season opened to march out with
an army and go and attack what's now
Iraq and so Octavian is 19 years old
waiting for Caesar to learn how to fight
a war while Caesar went and attacked
what is called parthia Caesar never
makes it and so Octavian gets news that
Caesar has died and that Octavian is
Caesar's heir Antonia too had the whale
publicly read out which was a mistake
Antony thought that he would be Caesar's
heir when sorry did Antony he he ordered
that the will be read out not knowing
what was in it is that true
apparently Wow misstep yeah Antony's
idea was that the way you can get people
to fully turn on Brutus was to have a
public speech I mean the Caesar or
Shakespeare does this well to have a
public speech in which you talk about
what Caesar did why it matters and
display for them
the wounds that were inflicted on Caesar
and Antony does this in the reading of
the will in which Caesar gives money to
every Roman citizen and gives parkland
to every Roman citizen and also notice
that Octavian is the heir
I think Antony had a sense of what was
in there I don't know if he knew that
Octavian was named I think he didn't but
this was part of the way that Antony
turned this uncertainty about what the
murder of Caesar meant into enthusiastic
embracing of Caesars legacy right but
what that know is Octavian now had the
possibility to claim Caesars legacy
because he was Caesar's heir and by err
we don't mean he was the next Emperor
because that wasn't a thing right yeah
he was the person who inherits Caesars
stuff he inherited Caesars property but
the condition was that he had to take
Caesars name
now if Octavian is thirty he could use
this and leverage this and build this
into a really effective way to confront
the opponents of Caesar and Antony the
allies of Caesar who potentially would
be opposed to Octavian but I say viens
19 he can't even hold office yet he's
not eligible to be even considered for
the leading offices in the Roman state
he has no political experience he has
really not a great deal of personal
experience and Antony's assumption and
even Octavian's mother's assumption was
that probably it's in his best interest
to not do this but if he was gonna do
this he's probably gonna die it wouldn't
he would do this we mean claim the
legacy and and go and try to avenge
Caesar what Octavian decides contrary to
everybody's advice was to go and claim
the legacy of Caesar and actually start
using the name of Caesar as a way to
build a political support structure for
himself and the maneuverings that
Octavian is able to do are amazing he's
a pretty confident guy especially when
you consider his age but I think the
other thing that is really shocking
about update
Cesar did not want to wage civil war in
a way that was vicious Cesar was
particularly interested in pardoning
adversaries he didn't want to take
proper to your lives unless he needed to
he had learned from what had happened in
the civil wars in the 80s where he was
one of the victims of Scylla he had
learned that this is just this makes it
very difficult for the state to come
back together it makes it very difficult
for you to exercise authority later and
it's much better to to wage a civil war
in such a way that you rehabilitate as
many people as you possibly can
Octavian I think had learned from Caesar
that that is an excellent way to get
yourself killed and I think there's a
lot to be said about the about the
desirability of what Caesar was trying
to do Octavian couldn't take that chance
and wouldn't take that chance
so Octavian was vicious when he fought
civil wars and I think what we see
throughout history is most people who
are vicious when they fight civil wars
tend to be vicious after they win as
well
what Octavian was able to do was to
pivot and create a structure where he
was in charge of the state but the
viciousness more or less ended and part
of that is because he killed most of the
opponents who mattered he's a godfather
yeah yeah but but then part of that is
he figured out ways to create a new
structure after the civil wars ended
that incorporated all of the people who
are meaningful in ways that gave them a
stake in the success of his enterprise
and made the barriers to opposing him
extremely high right and made it
extremely unlikely that anybody who
opposed him would have any kind of
positive outcome for themselves at all
and was there any specific final tipping
point where Octavian then Augustus
became you know went from the chief of
the Republic to being the Emperor the
process is incredibly fascinating he
starts out as somebody with no army and
no office just a name he comes to Rome
is able to leverage this into the
support of some of Caesars troops who he
hires or he recruits with the idea that
they're going to go
fight brutus and cassius he tries to use
them against Antony who has now become
an enemy that doesn't work the troops
refused to fight each other because they
both are cesarean he ends up getting
those troops enrolled in the Republican
army that decides to go and confront
Antony after Anthony breaks with the
Senate in the course of that battle the
two commanders the Senate had chosen end
up dying Octavian then is fully in
charge of this army the Senate refuses
to acknowledge this so Octavian marches
the army on Rome and makes an alliance
with Antony they then defeat Brutus and
Cassius and Antony and Octavian fall out
and over the course of the late 40s and
into the 30s Octavian manages to
maneuver things so that his position
visa vie ance and he continually gets
stronger and Antony gets increasingly
marginalized until in 31 BC Octavian's
forces defeat Antony's forces and then
in 30 Octavian chases Antony invades
Egypt conquers Egypt Antony dies
Cleopatra dies in Egypt becomes a Roman
territory the genius that Octavian has
when he takes Egypt this the structure
in Egypt going all the way back to the
pharaonic period was that the the
sovereign in charge of Egypt had a huge
amount of royal land this in the
Republic would have become public land
that belonged to the Republic but
Octavian takes it as his land and what
Octavian then does is he adds that into
all of the private property that he had
from Caesars estate and all of the
property that he had confiscated from
other people and he has an entire
separate entirely separate ledger sheet
and he ensures effectively that the
public finances are almost always in
deficit and anytime there's a crisis he
bails him out using his private
resources now his private resources
include Egypt so if there's significant
yeah but he makes it very clear every
time this happens that he is stepping in
as a private citizen and bailing out the
public when there's a problem
and I think this actually is the
unacknowledged tipping point this is
what makes the Empire work
he makes soldiers loyal to him and makes
sure that they are paid in a way that
they understand he's paying them
whenever anything of substance seems to
go wrong he makes sure that he fixes it
and he makes sure everybody understands
that this comes from his private
resource yes and so what he has done is
he's left the Republic the public thing
to function but he's made it clear that
it functions very badly and for the
state to actually work for Roman lives
to actually work the private resources
of Augustus as he becomes our essential
you can't have this function in any
meaningful way without him present and
this is the genius of how he pivots from
this horrible vicious Civil War II er to
somebody who creates an enduring
political structure that exists for 1500
years how long was it between the death
of Caesar and Augustus becoming Emperor
Caesars assassinated in March of 44
Augustus wins the Civil War with Antony
in 30 BC and then comes up with a
political settlement in 16 years about
14 years he 14 you and then coming back
with you yeah and then comes up with a
political settlement in 27 that will be
the basis of what his power is but the
historian Tacitus who's writing in the
second century sums up I think very
succinctly why this all works for so
long
Augustus is Emperor for 41 years you
know he's on the political scene for 17
years before that but he's emperor for
41 years average Roman lives for 50
years
Tacitus writes that there wasn't a Roman
left who remembers the Republic and he's
right Augustus dies at 76 years old he
was 19 when he comes on to the political
scene there's nobody left who remembers
a functional Republic so this idea
because it had previously happened in
the times of the Republic that there'd
be like temporarily a king or a dictator
or whatever right in times of emergency
or someone would you know claim that and
then get
deposed but now that so the idea that
after Augustus we go back to be public
it sort of dissolved or just over time
yeah nobody even remembers when you
think of who's left maybe one percent of
the people are over seventy six but they
don't you know that the sixties were an
okay time for the Republic but to
actually remember it and understand what
was going on
you're probably twenty years old at that
point so you have to be 96 yeah to have
any meaningful memory of a republic
that's actually functioning as it should
yeah there's hardly anybody like that
and if you mattered you were dead yeah
they someone ensured that you were dead
somewhere between when you were born and
thirty and also as we as we mentioned
before with Caesar
I mean Augustus was you know took power
with great popular acclaim
it wasn't resistance he didn't force
himself on Rome I mean maybe he did by
imaginations but they certainly went
along with it
right I think that there is there's
other there's another interesting moment
that happens in every Imperial reign
you know there's generally speaking when
emperors take power in the Roman the
Roman period a lot of them die very
quickly that makes sense right you've
taken power if you don't secure power
and you die but if you make it through
the first couple of years many of them
then lasts until about 12 to 15 years in
and then there's another sort of spurt
of them getting assassinated and then if
they get past that that then they tend
to live out a natural life in any brain
for a very long time and I think that
you look at the progression of Augustus
there is a major crisis around 20 BC you
know when you're the Civil War ended in
31 now you have the generation that
remembers the Civil War is kind of
passing on into more senior positions
but then the people who are rising up
don't really remember the Civil War as
well and they're willing to challenge
him and what Augustus manages to be back
this challenge but then he withdraws
from Rome and he stops providing that
money and he stops providing that
security and he lets
things kind of go to hell for a little
while oh and steps back in when he's
asked to but that's what really secures
power for him is this moment where he
reminds the next generation of what the
Republic is actually like yeah you know
do you really want the Republic because
it means mob violence it means not
enough food it means
disasters that afflict the city that you
can't recover from that's what the
Republic is he was truly brilliant
politician oh yeah yeah and and he was
willing to do anything that was
necessary but he was also I think enough
of a forward thinker that he could
understand how to prevent crises from
happening before they did if they did
happen he was willing to do whatever it
took to resolve that crisis in his favor
but he was also very capable of
foreseeing what crises might occur and
doing what he could to head them off
five years before they might emerge and
later on either later in Augustus is
Reagan or after him were there later
flare-ups where people tried to restore
the Republic no no not in a meaningful
way because they were basically happy or
because it was basically fruitless
Augustus created a system that worked
very very well and subsequent Emperor's
use this system and they incorporate
increasing numbers of people and so when
you look at the the pattern of how power
is allocated across the Empire what you
see is that the the people empowered by
Augustus were the people more or less of
sort of families that had gotten
citizenship but had not yet risen to the
highest levels of Roman offices and and
editorial offices during the Republic
and so Augustus takes people who are
powerful wealthy but to a degree
outsiders and gives them the highest
tier of responsibilities as you move to
the next dynasty what you see is they
start expanding and bringing in people
from Spain and northern Italy and
southern France and Greece and building
out you know they're they're loyalists
with the sort of next group of people
where who works of patronage and loyalty
and and what you do is you you create
these people are incredibly loyal to you
at the expense of people whose star is
kind of faded and there's always these
moments of tension where you don't quite
yet reach the point where those new
people are powerful enough to resist and
you might die if that happens but if you
get over that hump yeah you have a very
loyal and very powerful base of support
next dynasty the Spaniards become
emperors and they start bringing in a
lot more people from the Greek world to
form this new core aristocracy the next
dynasty is North Africans and Syrians
and and so that what Augustus was able
to create was a dynamic structure that
if managed well everybody had an invite
everybody who mattered could be made to
have an investment in this being stable
and this is this is the genius of the
Empire is he creates a structure out of
chaos that is stable it gets people
interested in it it gets people invested
in its success and it becomes
self-sustaining in a way that the
Republic never really was it is an
amazing story in many ways I'm going to
I have two questions like that but
they're both very big questions that we
can decide you know how long to go on
about them could we be in the discussion
we've just had accused of you know
buying into a great man theory of
history where we've given a lot of
credit to these particular figures and
you know we've glanced at the mentioning
well there was growing inequality in
Rome and there were you know this way of
having armies that were loyal to
individuals rather than the state over
their systemic effects that would have
had the same effects or the systemic
forces that would have led to the
dissolution of the Republic just as well
even forward different cast of
individual characters I mean I think
this is a great question and I suppose
what I would say is if we are to look at
big historical cycles you know I don't
think that there's a great man theory of
history and I don't think there's a
great system theory of history but I
think a robust system can restrain any
individual and a capable individual can
overthrow a weak system
I think that if Augustus had been born
in 263 ya know he would not have become
Emperor he would have probably become
consul he would have been very
successful in working through Republican
channels we might know his name but
really he would have been a creature of
that system because that system was
strong it was robust it set rules that
really couldn't be broken and there
wouldn't have been any capacity for him
to do what he had done if you took
Skippy Oh Africa us out of that robust
system of the third century BC and
plunked him down in 50 BC could he have
become Emperor I think he probably could
have yeah and I think he might have
wanted to be but this the time in which
he was living the Republic was robust
enough that it set the rules for our
political activity and you couldn't
challenge them effectively and no one in
the right mind who was capable would
have tried yeah I think that does make
sense so my other question then is even
way way bigger scope you know he told a
certain story and there's obvious
parallels to present-day events but
they're not perfect right in many ways
they're different how do we choose which
stories to tell about history like
what's in our minds well there's a
number of things we could say and
there's many different sources and we
highlight this and we emphasize that we
ignore that I mean how much of it is our
perspective that we're bringing to
things how much it can be can be
universalized or made scientific or
something like that Wow that's a
wonderful question I think the short
answer to that is to speak on a personal
level you know I am interested in the
stories that help me think in a more
broad way about the world around me that
doesn't mean that the world around me is
the same as the world that I'm
describing or I'm working with it's
radically different you know as we said
at the outset we don't live in a society
with slavery we don't see human beings
in the same way that Romans did the
notion that's so deep in Roman society
the humans are property is something
that is so antithetical at the very cool
or to what our society believes that
these places are radically different
from each other but Roman history gives
us tools to think with there are
analogies we can make but there are also
just possibilities that we can entertain
and it gives us a set of tools that we
can use to imagine what futures might be
what outcomes - events could potentially
be and what kinds of responses make
sense or don't make sense to the events
around us you know history isn't destiny
but history does give us a sense of what
could happen and it gives us tools to
think with and it's a lot easier I think
to grasp the world around us if we just
have more information about what
possible outcomes might be I think that
is a beautiful place to end and watch
thanks so much for being on the mind
free podcast thank you so much
[Music]